Rose were here at the London Film and
comic convention you have massive queues
all day lots of people wanted your
autograph and to speak to you how are
you finding it I'm finding it is so much
fun it is wonderful to meet everybody
and the fact that there are you know
kind of like fans for the show is just
an amazing thing
so yeah I'm having a great time thank
you we've done two massive shows as well
haven't you Game of Thrones and Downton
Abbey what's it like being part of
something so big it's incredible I feel
so fortunate I feel incredibly credibly
lucky and it is wonderful to be able to
you know to be given these opportunities
to be in such fantastic shows that they
both on what have you enjoyed about Game
of Thrones um the locations going to
Iceland shoot for series 2 was just
phenomenal and I'd never been to the
country before so it was wonderful to
kind of like get a scope of everything
and also like the storyline in my
character I loved the character that I
played in Game of Thrones so yeah
there's wonderful and how about
downswings obviously completely
different with that so different so
different I mean it could be on the
other end of the scale with me um but ya
know that was a lot of fun as well I had
a few more time coming out yeah can we
look forward to next from you um well
series 3 is about to start for Game of
Thrones so so that's going to be like
kicking off quite soon so yeah that'd be
exciting what we expect from you in that
oh well I'm not sure if I'm actually
allowed to give too much away too much
away but um but yes I once again we meet
some new characters some new characters
come into the show and and you know
she's gonna have to wait and see I'm
sorry I don't know and just very quickly
but now as good as well haven't you
coming out edge Alicia tell me a little
bit about that yes well and that is that
is a film written and directed by old
Parker and um that was great fun great
fun to film and and yeah it's a rather
heart-rendering story played by Dakota
Fanning who
main part but yes maybe so it's a lovely
someone going to be a wonderful
wonderful film I can't wait to see I
haven't seen it yet so I'm looking
forward to seeing it void sing it is
we're looking forward to this season
through ago if Aaron's good leg thank
you very much love you speaking
you